Good morning, 12.
Good morning, sir. Good morning, sir. Good morning, sir.
Good morning. Good morning, sir. Good morning. Good.
Alright, so, uh, let's start now, sir has also joined.
So,
So meanwhile, uh, today what we are going to do is couple
of things that we will first see the survey will cover LSTM,
long short term memory.
That is what we have planned.
And then followed by that I will cover some, some of the
points which are still left with the RNN.
Uh, so in terms of the different types of the RNN
and architecture, which are possible.
And, uh, and, uh,
a little bit on the back propagation in the RNN,
which is slightly different from the ENN.
Okay? So because in the RNN what we do, we
build an architecture with a time stamp manner
that is what we have seen, right?
So then how the back propagation, how the gradient flow
with the time stamp, that is
where it is a little bit different.
And I'll try to give you that perspective that how does the
back replication happens in the hour, right?
So this is what we have planned for today.
So we, we are roughly left with four weeks, I guess,
because 22nd February is the last working
day is for this semester.
And now we'll move towards the LSTM or not two class.
It'll take to understand that.
And I guess we are on track, we will be able to cover, cover
till, till the, till, the sequence
to sequence model and intention.
And from transformer, uh, we will we'll, uh,
see in the class.
Yeah. Yes, sir. Uh, good morning, sir.
Good morning. Good morning. Good morning, sir.
Good morning. Morning. Good morning, sir. Good morning.
Good morning, sir. Good morning, all Good morning.
Good morning, sir. Good morning. Good morning.
So, um, shall we start?
Uh, So good morning all.
Uh, as, uh, Dr.
Sunil was mentioning, um, uh,
sequence knowledge modeling, uh,
I is required in very important machine learning tasks.
There were non neural network approaches.
Stochastic modeling like Marco chain,
all those things were available.
Neural networks community also, uh, wanted
to come up with such an architecture.
So, which resulted in the proposal
of this recurrent neural network.
Okay? Now, with this, then,
once the sequence modeling is done, so
after that, now they started seeing some challenges,
uh, in the, uh,
recurrent neural networks.
And that, uh, was famously put out as what is called
short term dependency versus long-term dependency.
For example, if you consider a conventional language
modeling that we do in natural language processing,
the goal there is to, uh, given, um,
one word or a set of words in a given sequence,
predict the next word.
Okay? For example, if, if I take, you know,
this phrase, the clouds are in the sky.
That sky word is to be producted.
You are given clouds are in the then know as an, uh,
prior knowledge of this language model
that is clouds are in the, the, then you'll, you'll fill up
that gap as, uh, sky.
So to predict this word sky,
I do not need any further information here, okay?
And such a thing is called as a short term dependency.
So it can be handled using, uh, recurrent neural network,
uh, uh, conditions.
On the other hand, if you take few examples, you know,
where there may be a requirement for long-term depend,
it may not be available locally in the form,
phrase or sentence.
You may have to look for, uh, much
before few sentences
or a paragraph to predict
the word or information at a given place.
For example, if you look at this, uh, no,
about three sentence paragraph.
So I am from a South Indian family, specifically Karnataka,
but settled in Delhi.
Then are you sharing your, uh,
Screen?
Oh my God, somebody should tell me. No. Uh, I,
somebody should tell me immediately once I start talking.
Yeah,
These are, is it visible?
Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yeah.
So I was talking about short-term dependency versus
long-term dependency.
See, this dependency part in some extent,
we have studied in language modeling where given a sequence
of words, how do you predict the, um,
next word in the sequence,
but that is only in a local sense.
For example, you consider a phrase,
the clouds are in the sky.
A prediction of this word sky
doesn't require any further information.
It just, these past few words are sufficient for me.
And such a dependency is called a short term dependency.
So I was telling you about this long-term dependency,
for example, um, I have a paragraph like this.
I am from a South Indian family, specifically Karnataka,
but separate in Delhi.
I had spent most of my childhood
and done schooling as well as college education in Delhi.
So apart from Canada, I can speak fluent Hindi.
Also that word Hindi, um,
is filled here based on the knowledge
of the previous two sentences.
Okay? Suppose if I consider short term dependency, that is,
I take only this sentence apart from Canada,
I can speak fluent.
It is ambiguous for me if I don't have the knowledge
of the previous sentences, okay?
And, uh, this, that's where, um,
the short term dependency,
if I review from a short term dependency point of view, uh,
the next part is probably name of the language I can speak.
Fluent dash also means we know it's, uh,
another language apart from ada.
I can also speak some other language,
but I, it's difficult for me to tell which language is that,
uh, specifically, okay?
Until I have additional knowledge.
So on the other hand, if I'm getting exposure
to the past two sentences without any ambiguity, I can put
that, uh, information here.
So, uh, to narrow down which language we need, the context
of Delhi from further long back
and such a dependency is called
as long term dependencies called this long-term dependency.
Okay? Um,
and now, um, this is an example just for a slide purpose.
It may be possible. Now you can extend your
imagination for much more.
Know, maybe you used it in the previous
to previous paragraph.
You have described something
and that knowledge is required in this paragraph.
Okay? So in that way,
which piece of information in a sequence
will be useful, in which context it may vary from short term
to in a long term manner, long term can be extended,
uh, much beyond.
Okay? That is, there is a gap
between the relevant information
and the point where it is needed may become very large.
So when we are talking in the context
of such long-term dependency,
their recurrent neural networks are known
to be not doing well.
There we are not discounting the RNs,
but this is what, suppose if I'm,
my sequence modeling is only short term based on short-term
dependency, then R ns are still the best architectures.
But in a task, you need a long-term information.
Of course, you can use LSM for short term also,
but, uh, as we will see in the following slide there, uh,
the architecture is much more complicated in LS
tm compared to R and n.
So naturally it'll take more competition
time, all those things.
So, so depending on that is how no, uh, of course
what we have done is the modified version of RNN.
We are calling it a long short term memory,
long short term memory, recurrent neural network.
But in, uh, literature terminology over time,
they remove the word RNN, they just use using the
word LST.
Okay? So what the, the,
the point that we have to keep is, um,
as the gap grows between
where it is needed versus from which are
the RNs become unable to learn that long-term information.
So, uh, that is where no, when the length
of the sequence is large,
RNS start showing degradation in performance due
to vanishing or exploding gradient to issue.
So r does, RNN will not be able
to model the long term context information.
Of course, they can model the short term context
information, so
then people fail.
No, there is a need for modifying this RN architecture,
which can take care of both the short term context
and long term context.
Okay? So, so
accordingly know they modified that RNN cell
that we showed earlier, for example, uh, I will go to
that cell once before I come here, this RNN cell,
which is there, they look good into what is available here.
Then how we can modify the internal design
of this RNN cell, which is not about the neural network, uh,
to model both
long-term context information
and short term context information.
So if there is any, for example, if I take this RN in cell,
there's a tan hyperbolic, I use the past, uh, hidden state
or recurrent cell information
and the current input through the weight metrics, pass it
through an output function to get the, the, um, output of,
uh, this uh, uh,
so this figure kindly remember this, we are trying to
modify this RNN structure such
that it can accommodate both short term context
and long term context.
And the this equation,
you please remember there are two inputs.
One is HD minus and other is XT through the weight metric.
And that is positive through
or to function damage that you kindly remember.
Now, coming back to here,
um, to feedback in RNN cells, now
to create the know, the capture, the sequence knowledge,
we are keeping that feedback.
That is what the HT HT minus one,
they're all sequence knowledge.
Now I have, I need two feedback.
One to keep track of the short term context,
which is the normal RNN operation.
The other one to keep off the occasional long-term
information that is required.
Okay? As I told you, three paragraphs
before, I feel, oh, this is an important piece
of information, I may use it at later point of time.
Okay? Then I can onboard
that two long-term context
and keep it for, you may not use it very frequently,
but wherever it is required, you use it.
Once it is purpose is over, you delete that
and onboard some other long-term context information.
So if you see the difference between short-term context
and long-term context,
the short term context is essentially local sense,
no within a phrase or sentence like sequence.
Whereas long term context,
we are talking about paragraph or paragraphs.
I'm telling from an NLP point of view that you can extend it
for any sequence mon so
and so.
Now, the first they thought was we need two feedback parts.
One, to keep track of the short-term context information.
Another to keep track of the long,
long-term context information.
And then since there are two, uh, uh,
see feedback information,
I should also have a control mechanism to
uh, know onboard this information.
Short term context information, long term control, that is
where they brought the concept of what is called,
which is very relevant.
In no digital electron gates are no just like no,
depending on the input
and the one, the output will be set or reset.
So I can use a gait mechanism as a communication
between the short term context and long-term condition.
Just like RNN, we continuously cap follow with the,
that HT HT minus one.
That is a short term context that will be there.
They'll go on using that as you move from one point in time
to the next point in time.
But whenever you feel like this short term conduction will
be useful at a later point of time, then you onboard into
that feedback line belonging to the long term context.
So that is where they, they,
they thought about two feedback lines
and a few gates
as a control mechanism between the two lines.
So long term context and short term context.
So that's where now they modified the basic recurrence
seller foreign to accommodate the same.
And this resulted in
what is called a short term memory neural
network, LSTM network.
Okay? Um, so I was telling all of you,
because when you go for LSTM, it is very difficult
to write the equation.
That's where they show it pictorially.
For example, this is an RNN information
because we are only modifying the RNN cell architecture.
If you see this, this upper line is the HT HT line
that are feedback sequence information from
the previous cell.
For example, I'm talk,
I'm talking about the current incident of time as t
the previous incident of time as T minus one.
Next incident of time T plus one. Okay?
So accordingly, suppose when I want
to compute the feedback information
that our sequence knowledge, which I have to pass it
to the next instance, that is ht, okay?
First XT is considered,
and the previous sequence information,
HT minus one is considered.
And these links will have the weights. Okay? The weights.
And this indicates you are going to add both of them
and pass it through a ton hyperbolic function to get ht.
So I now, uh, please, you know, pass or a while
and think about this diagram.
I will go back to the previous slide to show this.
This equation we are shown HT is equal
to 10 hyperbolic cough,
HT minus one plus xt.
That we said these two connection, when they're merging,
we are adding them and the weights are not shown here.
That is implied. Okay?
And this is, uh, no the simplest possible, uh,
representation of an RNN operation, RNN cell operation.
Okay? So let me go back to
that, uh, slide.
Ah, so this HT output
depends on XT and HT minus one, okay?
And then these links are multiplied
by refractive respective weight metrices.
Then that whole thing is ED
through a ton ilic function to get ht.
That is the this equation representation.
And this is what we are showing in a simple pictorial manner
there instead of always dealing with the equations.
So HD minus one XP
submission of them followed through a function, do I get hd?
And this hd, if you want, you can pass it on
to further output weight function to get the output,
the respective output.
I hope it is clear. I is it fine?
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Now let me go to the next, uh, this is
where now we get scary.
Okay? First, if you are understand this,
then we can appreciate this LS tm.
So in the LSTM, the same
TT minus one T plus one is there.
What goes inside?
Uh, the LSTM as I told, there are two feedback lines.
One line running in the bottom, one line running in the top.
You see the HT is tapd from the lawyer line.
That means to say the conventional RNN operation is
through this horizontal line lawyer, horizontal line, okay?
Lawyer horizontal line.
So then that means to say,
as we move from one time instead of the next time instant,
if you tap the lower output line lawyer feedback line,
that is where your continuous RN operations
will uh, be there.
Whenever you require a long term context information, I I,
this upper line will carry the long term
context information.
It may not be used at every instant in
time, every instant in time.
I'm only doing the normal short-term context, uh,
uh, information.
Whenever you want
to require a long-term context information,
then only I tap the output link.
Otherwise it come, just keeps the long-term context moves on
from one place to the next place.
For example, if you, the previous RNN cell, which I showed,
no, that is nothing but this HT minus one xt then followed
by, suppose I come to this tan hyperbolic,
this tan hyperbolic line
and this output, what I have at the output
of the tan hyperbole, okay?
Uh, hope this is visible. I arrow mark.
Okay, so you see this horizontal line moving
that is this output at this point
where my cursor is standing, which is nothing bad HT minus
multiplied by the WHH XT multiplier, WXT some would do
that summation is available for all these four links.
Now I come to third link, pass it
through a bowling at the output.
The, what I get is that hd. What I get is that hd. Okay?
So now, uh, the, um, so
we are, these two are underline.
Please note this rectangular blocks,
if you see this low rectal blocking,
this is a neural network layer.
This, all these things shown are neural network layers.
And this circle shows point wise operation you are doing,
whether it is multiplication or addition
and vector transfer.
When I say this, R marks vector transfer,
and this is concatenate, they add them.
That is what is the meaning.
And when you split, you copy the, uh,
vectors into two locations.
Okay? Now you see,
um, this into
that is cross symbol indicates you are going to multiply
this, uh, incoming
long-term context information with the vector
coming from here.
And how, what is this vector value?
It depends on, suppose I have the previous instant XT
and HT minus one summed through, then pass it
through a Sigmoidal network, pass it
through a Sigmoidal network, okay?
And, uh, the output of the sigal network is nothing
but uh, the vector that I use it for
in a layman term, typically sigmoidal output will be
either zero or one.
So if it is zero, then the long term context
will be reset here.
If it is one, then it is passed on further. Okay?
So that is how, uh, this operation of this happens.
Similarly, the other gates also will perform.
We will see how, uh, know they're used there. Okay?
So essentially if you see this, there are three gates here.
Wherever X marks is there, know, there is a gate here,
there is one gate here, there, there's one gate here
and there is a one gate here.
And there are, since there are three gates,
the nomenclature are given separately.
We'll see that. Okay?
So, um, the, the,
the whole complexity here is, um,
I, whenever I find a useful information that can be unloaded
as a long-term context information, I will push
that onto the top line.
That is one thing.
Second thing is whenever I require
the long-term context operation
to be used in a specific time instead, then I will use that
third one is whenever I feel
that this long-term context information is no more useful,
then I can remove that or forget that,
or we can say no, uh, make it zero or something.
So that, that's where there is, um, um,
agate operation accordingly,
one gate is called a fargate gate.
There is an operation that Mr.
Say in the current instant,
whatever the sequence knowledge I have, this is useful
as a long-term contact information.
That's where I will update the long-term contact cell
using that update gate.
And then another thing is what is called output gate.
So whatever the output I have, I want
to convert into whatever the output
for the next sequence of information.
That's why that is called the output gate.
So accordingly, we have forget gate,
update gate and output gate.
So that is how, uh, so when you look at this structure,
so now don't, uh, um, what I say
get panicked by the, um, the complicated structure.
If you look at, there's no very simple,
there are four neural networks inside one three
of them acting as gates.
Another one is the, uh, the output that, uh,
coming from the RNN cell
and uh, then know the gate three gate operations to perform
storing or removing or updating the long-term conduction.
Okay? Now let us see, um,
only, uh, the upper line, which is this,
we call it as a cell at any point of time,
this recurrent neur network cell
or RNN cell we call, Okay?
So then, um, the upper line, this RNN cell, this is,
see this lawyer line is the conventional RN and operation.
That's why HT minus one HT will be there.
Upper line is a long term context information
that is called a CT minus one CT line.
That, okay, that's CT represent the, uh, cell state.
So, uh, the cell state is horizontal line running
through the top of the diagram.
LSTM can remove
or add information to the cell state regulated
by the structure of structures called gates.
Okay? So that is only this to take care
of the information flow in the long term context line,
top line, all that gates concept is there.
Otherwise, uh, in the lawyer line, you can just, uh, uh,
positive hyperbolic function.
That itself will be your, uh,
short term context information.
So when I consider gates, let us consider the structure
of a gate sigmoidal network, neural network.
Is there input, is sigmoidal output is zero
or one in the range?
Zero to one. Okay? So then this input is there.
You multiply that so naturally, so
this gates essentially has the function they perform
as the confunction they perform is optionally.
They let information through, okay?
That's what they, so this modal neural network, uh,
will have a point voice multiplication.
The sig modal output will
or value will between zero and one.
It's not always binary.
It is as you told, no sigma does zero to one just
as an exceeding a know, uh, what I call, um,
extreme information.
I'm telling suppose if it is zero, sigmar output is zero,
that means say you multiply zero vector
with the input vector here, every value will become zero.
That's why that means
to say the long term context information,
which is coming from so many times in states
is I'm convinced that that is no more required.
Multiply with zero all will be removed, and
accordingly the cell state becomes zero here.
On the other hand, if it is one, then multiply with one so
that you just pass on further the further instance in time.
Okay? So letting, uh, if it is zero, let it let nothing
through one, let everything through.
And, uh, in between also zero to one, it can vary
and it can be 0.1, 0.2 individual dimensions.
Also, you can change that is the way it can happen.
So accordingly, this LSTM S3 gates to protect
and control cell state.
That is that in long term context information.
Now let us take the forget gate part.
This is the first forget gate.
Here I have HT minus one xt, okay?
And, uh, uh, we are using a different equation here,
which is nothing but WEF is nothing,
but it has both WHH as well
as W-X-X-X-H
and that multiplied with that, um, h ST minus on xt,
there's a vector notation.
Plus BF means that bias function F is indicate
to show no, it's a forget gate, uh,
neural network output output.
So you see this now the, the forget gate,
this forget gate, uh, will have, uh,
it has two weight metrices inside one belonging
to HT minus one arm belong to xt,
but this wa weight metrics is not same
as conventional RNN weight metrics
because this is for the forget purpose, okay?
And this whole thing is passed through a sigal output
anywhere from zero to one,
and that is the ft, which is coming.
FT value is a vector anywhere from zero to one.
And this FT will decide what information
to throw away from the cell state.
The decision that is made by the sigma layer is called
that forget gate layer.
Um, so it'll know,
it'll look at HD minus one, the previous, uh,
short term context information and the current input
and outputs between zero
and one for each number in the cell state stream.
So one means completely keep this dimension,
zero means completely get rid of this dimension.
So that is the purpose of forgetting it.
So any, any doubt here, any of you?
Yes. Yes sir. Yes sir. Okay. Yeah.
Yes, please. So for gate,
we are multiplying here.
Mm. And for the same here, when we are taking RNN gate, uh,
and output, then we are doing addition.
What is the purpose of this sir? Both. Both.
We are adding the text. No sir.
Okay, so you see this lawyer link
before this sigmoidal there we are doing addition, okay?
Or we are. So this is a matrix notation of this is not,
uh, no matrix notation of there is two vectors
and, uh, metrics notation of the W weight metrics
that suppose this is same as if you,
I have to go to, uh, that that operation is same
as this only, but just for, you know,
compact notation they have shown in the matrix format.
Okay, let me come to this point.
Now, this operation is same as the previous operation, only
to make it a neur network operation.
I'm adding that bias vector, pass it
through a SIG model network to get the network output
and here that multiplication that I will have, that is
for the long-term context.
Uh, I just, uh, know can you raise your
doubt again, Rajesh here?
Yeah, sir, we are saying that uh,
for L-L-S-T-M gate we are multiplying
for the RNN gate output, uh, which is 10 H. We are, uh,
No, there's no 10 here.
You see this link? There is no 10 CH HT minus on ST
is somewhat as input to the sigal network.
There's no danage coming here.
Yes, sir. Okay.
Yes sir. So this, my question is about multiplication
and addition, sir?
Yes. So where is the, where is your,
where are you looking for the addition?
Uh, uh, about 10 H output, sir?
No, there is no 10 H here in this slide.
There is no 10 H no, this is model.
Yeah, yeah. In the next, in the, uh, no, no in this
we'll move forward.
Ah, uh, for 10 H output. I am saying so not about that.
This one? Uh, yeah, full. This one, huh? Yeah, this one sir.
Hey, that I will come later. Okay?
So I'm just asking if you have any doubt for this?
Yeah, why we are multiplying here? Yes, sir.
No, that we will see that.
We will see when I come to there, I'll explain,
but first tell me about this.
Forget gate information, whether you got the hold or not.
Yes, sir. That I got it.
Yeah, sir, one question here.
This square bracket, HT minus one xt, uh, comma.
So how do we visualize, I mean,
I know this is a me WF is a metrics correct?
It's not a vector. I think it's a metrics, right?
IT metrics. How do we visualize this, sir?
This is same as, so, uh, um, I'll,
I'll go back to again, I do not have a better example to
show I have to go to this.
Only you can visualize as same as this instead of tanach,
uh, I have sigmoidal.
Uhhuh, okay?
So that is, uh, one thing, uh,
and we then you'll have,
so this weight plus one plus
And bias, that is fine.
So that is fine. Now there in that square racket you had HT
and you had also xt comma, comma separate.
So what are we doing to H and um, H
and X in that square bracket? What are we doing?
So the WEFF, ah, what you have WF you have no, ah,
that is nothing, but it has two metrices.
One is WHH and WXH. Okay.
Ah, the dot, if you see w hh multiplies HT minus one, ah,
WHH multiplies.
Uh, so the, oh,
Okay. So
it is this basically this inside this curly bracket is
what is expected in that square bracket?
Yes. I mean the w is they took in the W outside
as a generic notification, correct?
Correct, correct. Oh, okay. Got it sir.
And plus sigma, Sigma will there
to indicate the neur network output.
Any neur network output, we know no WX plus B like that?
Yeah, yeah, agree. Okay, got it sir.
Thank you. Thank you, sir.
So that is how, let us assume, see this is
a simple neuron function.
How do you get a neuron function?
You multiply weight vector with the input vector, right?
Plus the bias, get the neuron out. Yeah.
And this, you can extend it to one neuron, a number
of neurons in one layer.
Yeah, Several layers of neurons,
but the output function is sig mite.
Got it, sir. Thank you sir. Yeah,
No. And
Sir, here we are, uh, simulating this kind
of a clock per scenario kind of thing in a gate,
like if you have a clock per
We're simulating, uh, clapper only,
but not between binary zero, zero and one.
I yes explain with zero and one,
but it is anywhere from zero to one, zero
To one, yes.
Output. Yes. Yeah. Thank you.
So now we'll Rajesh margate will go,
this is called now one what?
Rajesh margate this.
So
yes, confusing.
So C for example,
you HT minus one xt, this is somewhat value is there
through that weight metrics.
You pass it through the Tana hyperbolic.
At this point of time it is nothing
but the RNN cells, the RN recurrent cell output ht,
which we are looking in the conventional, uh, um, RNA,
uh, C HT minus XT some
and waited through the spec link, followed
through a tib lic function output will be, um,
you were, um, what we call, um, um,
at the output of the, what you have is nothing
but the conventional RNN output, uh,
a conventional RNN, uh, RNN cell output,
RNN cell output, that is ht, which we are going
to pass it onto the next extent of time.
Okay? Now, what we are doing is
whether this, that sequence information
that I computed here in this time, whether
it has a relevance to become a long-term context information
or not, that is decided by this gate.
This is called update gate, like RH gate update,
update Gate sigma.
Okay? Yes, sir. You see it?
So there is an, this is also a neural network separately
that is W-I-T-I-E.
Is there HT minus one xt uh, plus bi?
Because this, no, this, it,
that is the update gate information.
Whether this current state information
should become part of the long-term context information
that is decided by this update, input gate, sorry,
not up input gate update gate I used to call.
Uh, that is done in gateway gate recurrent unit,
but this is called input.
Whether it should be, it should be inputted
to long-term context
or not, is decided by this input gate Rakesh.
Yes, sir. So
what this input gate will do is it'll decide
what new information to store in the cell state.
Cell state means long term context information.
Again, a sigmoidal layer input gate layer decides
which value to update.
So at tan hyperbolic layer creates a vector of new values.
This is nothing but your current cell state, ht,
and we are indicating it as c tilt means
because CT is for long-term context information,
we are exploring possibility of becoming part
of the this one, then combine these two
to create an update to the state.
This, this is a positive symbol here, plus symbol. Okay?
So update old cell state CT minus two new cell state ct.
Now for, for example, you see the sequence,
this is a plus sign here in the top line
above the standard will multiply.
Then what should be the updated information to come?
That is decided by the input gate
and this will be added to the current values.
Uh, the previous long-term information that is coming,
that is considered an extreme case.
This previous forget gate is zero.
Then it has multiplied every dimension of the input vector
as long-term conduction zero, zero vector is there
and now it says, okay,
this is the current information is useful
for long-term conduction.
That is decided by this input gate.
Say it is one, if it is zero, if it is one,
then the whole thing flows here, then
that will be added with the zero vector.
So accordingly, the current cell
short term context is onboarded
onto the long term context line or cell state.
That is the extreme case.
So on the other hand, no,
there is a variability due to sig model.
Accordingly this gets added. Okay,
Sir? One question.
Mm, yes.
Um, in, in the C tilt equation, uh, we have uh,
the curly bracket that WC is actually that same tanach,
which was happening earlier.
The R in 10. Ah, so it's a
Yes, yes.
So it's a true tan then I mean, no, no,
No, no, no. This
WCT minus is not tanach. This is simple.
Ah, it is that it is the weight
and then we are putting it inside of sigmoid.
We have a tanach here. Yes,
Yes. Okay. Okay.
So the context which is actually stored is
stored is a tan edge only,
and these sigmoids are basically input output gates.
They're like flags. Correct? Okay, got it sir.
Just like your logic gate zero one, is there one
of you ask now it is a continuous gate.
Okay, got it. Okay.
So, uh, why we are using only sigmoid function here.
Can't we use other activation?
No sigma I'm using here only to generate
that gait function output, continuous gait function.
It is zero to one. Any other output function,
which gives you zero to one value, you can use it.
There is no problem
Because the value range is zero to one.
Uh, correct. We're getting even intermediate.
Yes, yes. For example, see, just simplified understanding,
I took two extreme lines, zero
and one in a given vector, say there are end dimension.
One dimension can be zero, another dimension can be 0.2,
another dimension can be 0.5.
Okay? Like the dimension wise, multiplication will happen,
dimension wise, vector gets generated.
Hmm. So, so if you have any other say, uh,
function, which can generate that continuum value of zero
to one that you can also use.
But since Sigma is a well known thing people use,
Sir, actually, uh, it's coming from our grounding, like,
you know, at least I am an electronics engineer.
So gates were always either you pass the signal
or you block the signal.
So here, no incremental passing the info
and now it's, it's actually not a signal.
It's like information.
So that way it's not very intuitive, sir.
Correct? And not intuitive means
Not intuitive means it's difficult to understand.
If you know it's like a 0.6 something,
then partial information will flow
and you know, it'll sit in that context line. So
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no, it's possible that no, for example,
I can update the, you know, contextual information.
For example, I have a vector
of long-term context information.
I, I, uh, onboarded in a while reading one sentence.
I onboarded the long-term context information.
Now I will read the next sentence in
while referring the next sentence.
I feel that no, oh, in that vector,
this dimension needs to be updated.
Okay? So that is
where this manipulation comes into picture in zero two,
Right?
Yeah. Now
something called output gate.
Something called output gate. Okay?
Where suppose I have, uh,
the sig modal output, again, the sig modal output comes.
That is the only thing is three sigmas are there
and each of them have a separate weight functions.
That's why you know, this sigal function,
I'm calling the weight metrics as W zero.
Okay? And then the, uh,
this particular, um,
the particular output gate OT is given by the sigal output.
Separate W not is, uh, derived here.
And then now I have to generate the short term,
uh, sequence knowledge ht.
And that is done by, you have t multiplied by
10 hyperbolic of ct, whatever CT is there.
That CT flows through this ANA hyperbolic
and whether that should go as
your current state information is given by this ht,
this OT gate, again, it's sigal gate zero to one
and that's what it'll, so if you see just for example,
now, uh, let us consider X extreme cases just
to appreciate this.
XT minus and xt forget gate produces output as zero.
Then CT minus one for preserve so far made zero accordingly.
This input gate sig IAL makes it one,
whatever the current state output BOL exceed TCAP will go
and sit in the output line.
And this information is to be ED
through the anabolic to get hd.
This should appreciate. If you have any doubt, let me know.
See, conventionally, conventionally, let me, sorry, I have
to go back to that slide deck.
Um, see here
I take HT minus one xt, then pause it
through this WH, this one
and this, when I pause it
through anabolic function, I get hd.
What I'm doing in LSTM is I'm doing this,
this itself is onboarded onto the long-term
context information.
Okay? Then finally, I have to compute that cell state.
I have to pass it through to, okay, that is how I'm just
dropping down from the long-term context line
and passing to the 10 poly function to get ht.
So that is where I'm doing here.
So let me go back
to here.
If you see HT minus one XT positive,
the respective weight function, okay, then,
then it goes through this tan hyperbolic function
and uh, then it's a, uh, no, um, let me go
to this tan hyper function, then
this is the temporal context information I'm taking.
Okay? Then, uh,
then it gets onboarded onto the long-term context
information to get the current cell output.
I pass it through the T hyperbolic function.
That's how 10 hyperbolic function
of the long-term context information
and whether it should become HT
or not is multiplied by sigma.
If it is zero, then zero will be the sequence knowledge.
If it is one, whatever the function will come as output
or a varied version of that will come to this HT output.
That is how the, the HT is computed in the,
the, uh, the
short term context information is computed using the
long-term context information onboarded
through this output kit.
Multiply, I mean doing twice a 10 hit on the same input
would have any negative effects or something like that.
I, I, I'm not, uh, know
because the standard portfolio, no,
it'll only give you within minus one to plus one.
See this all vector values, I think there,
there should not be any challenge there.
That's how they'll put it
because this, they're not shown it as a neural network,
just only an output.
See what happens. Now, at this point
of time you have only a vector, modified vector.
That modified vector is passing rate and hyperbolic function
And, and weight would be Different in
Both these danage layers
Or no, in this tanach there is no weight here
you are just PAing through.
For example, Tanach, you are taking the ct,
there is no weight metrics, multiplication
just PAing through the tan.
If it is weight metrics is there,
I agree there will be significant variations.
Second,
I'm not able to hear you properly.
Can you
One second.
Ah, So second function using,
uh, like in the range of minus one to one,
Yeah, 10 is always from minus one
to plus one here also minus one
to plus one everywhere 10 is minus one to plus one
sigma is zero to one.
No. Yeah,
Sir. One question here.
You mentioned
that all these sigmoids have different weights
and correct, like OT has a w
and similarly, so again,
my previous question also coming here, so this w
is a new set of weights.
It has nothing to do with the original RNN, uh, which we
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay. The original RNN weights
are already multiplied here.
HT minus on xt,
when they combine this line happens no year cross
line merging happens.
That is nothing but already original RNN
weights are multiplied by them.
Okay? So sir, in these, uh,
in whatever we discussed today in this cell,
that's the only place wherein that uh,
they have already been multiplied
and all the rest is now re respective sigmoidal weights.
Yes, respective sigmoidal weights.
Okay, got it, sir. Yeah, sir, I mean, um,
a general question to design this would've taken a lot of,
um, intellect.
I don't think so. Okay. I don't think so.
See, I think looks complex. Uh, no.
Oh, that's where know, in the beginning I told
we need two feedback lines.
One, to keep short term context, one
to keep long term context.
That is a decision they made.
Then they told what, how do we, you know, transfer the info,
interplay the information within the short term
context or long term context.
So I just go through the bottom line short term context
without worrying about the long-term context.
I can work as a simple RNN.
Now if I want to incorporate long-term context information,
the long term information will travel from one instant
of time to the next instant of time sell.
So it may so happen, I go on keeping it at every point.
I check whether this long-term ion for me,
which I'm preserving from a long duration,
whether it is relevant now or we can throw it something
or we can modify like that all the top.
That is where they brought the concept of gates,
Right, sir? Got it.
But again, sir, I mean designing these gates
with it's not a simple zero one, it's like
that OID and also that
No, I agree. I agree.
Yeah, I agree.
That's, that's how the, so now you see now I will just, uh,
know this is the final, uh, no, uh,
cell state will go horizontally like this.
And uh, this gates we are discussing
and let me show you for example,
I told no an RNN was a simple structure like this.
Okay? Now the final
LSTM cell is like this.
Okay? So you see this, this is possible
through the tan hyperbolic function versus
apart from tan hyperbolic function.
I have three gates, three sigal gates.
I have one is the forget gate, um, in input gate
and output gate, okay?
So it is essentially interplay
for long term context information.
Now you see, suppose your goal is only
to model the short term context information in a,
in a particular task.
You can always use LSTM,
but you are now using overspending your requirement.
On the other hand, you in your task short term.
What I wanted to say is it is not,
it is not a generic statement to say that no,
always LSTM gives better performance than RNN, okay?
It depends on the task at your hand.
Your task needs only modeling
of the short term context information.
Then you will not gain much by LST. Okay?
Performance will not degrade.
But why do you want to do four times the effort than RNN
where the end result is only modeling the short
term contraction information?
Alternatively, if your job is to model as long term, yes,
LS TM is required.
Okay? So that is how it has been shown.
Uh, you can go through the slide deck,
of course the same information.
No, uh, please don't take it.
Uh, have a slight con uh,
uncomfortness in using this numbers.
One of my TA did it.
Um, for example, a sequence of length 50,
the RNN gives some 81% accuracy in
that sentiment classification.
This is also around 81.61 and hundred. It'll give you 82.
It gives me 85, whereas 200 it, I don't think I have
to worry about this numbers,
then it gives higher value or something.
So that, so what I want to say is, um,
when the sequence length increases, the RN
accuracy decreases gracefully, not like this.
And whereas LIUM will, uh, will hold the fault.
I think that I'll stop it here if you have any questions.
You have one question? Yes, sir. Just confirmations
Sir. Uh, whatever
LSTM layer we are using.
So here we only, we are filtering it, uh, the
relevant context, uh, which is useful for the network
because all the in, uh, four gate input
and output gate all where we are using sig mite only.
So we are filtering the context, which is relevant to, uh,
you know, our prediction or our works.
That is, is it correct? No.
Rakesh filtering means, which is useful
for our long-term purpose.
Yes, sir. Whenever there's a long-term purpose requirement,
then only all these ga these is three SIG model networks we
have, they're only gates.
They don't participate in capturing the information.
Yes, Sir. Okay.
What I'm doing is in the LS tm, the output is a combination
of short-term context and long-term context.
And that computation is done through the, going through
that twice and then getting,
Yeah. Good.
Thank you.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you
Sir. One question.
Okay.
Uh, Sunil? Yes.
Uh, so sir, uh,
how do this LS TM solve this vanishing variant,
which you mentioned an RNN, so which get, uh,
plays the major role to solve this
Wonderful, wonderful question, sir.
Ka, can I answer this question, sir?
If I, I just inferred it.
Uh, sir, I request to go to that slide, sir.
Uh, where you're shown that, uh, cell state,
Uh, let me, lemme tell me where I should.
So what I understand is that in RN we have that, um,
multiplication factor of the weights with the Excel state,
but what a peculiar I found here is
that we are doing a summation operator here, sir.
So even if we have a, my, uh, very small values,
we are not directly ing, we are adding to it.
So maybe with this summation operator, we are able
to address that, uh, manage grading problem.
Yeah, that's what I inform.
Yeah. So one way of no that the same thing.
That's correct. The one way of, uh, doing that is
I have a separate line.
See for example, if I don't have this upper line,
there is no way I can preserve the long-term context
information that will disappear due to
vanishing gradient problem.
Now, I have brought a solution for that
by putting this upper line.
I know this information is required at a long-term
contextual later point of time,
but if I just forget, it means I don't go
by short term condition of RNN
because of the vanishing gradient problem.
It'll disappear. That's why I'm artificially lifting up
and putting into the long term context
information and taking it forward.
Okay? Yes, sir. Yeah, thank you.
Yes, thanks.
Thank you, sir. So, uh,
uh, 10 o'clock.
So what we'll do is I will just stay on this topic.
I don't want to deviate much because,
and we'll try to, uh, discuss it in it in, uh, a
little more detail so
that your concept will be a little more clear.
I'll go ahead. Initial plan, different,
which I'll do next plus.
So first of all, what I will do as an add-on, I will
just tell you what is the, this long-term context
and short-term context and which lead to this vanishing
or exploiting gradient problem in RNN,
and that is what we are trying to address in the industry.
Okay? So for that one,
I have two different scenario here, okay?
The same task, the language modeling,
the next word prediction task,
and say that I have a sentence.
Sentence is, uh, here it is written, the,
sorry, your mobile number is selected as,
and there is a fill in the blank.
Suppose you have all these tokens in your hand
and you, you have to predict the next token, okay?
Now, because as a human being, we have seen this kind
of sentence multiple times, maybe via the messages,
what we receive in my mobile phone
or sometimes through some TV channel where people announce
that, okay, you're selected as winner
or you are selected as like person or so on.
So what happened because of this, this context, okay?
Because of this short context in the sense your mobile
number is selected as
and if suppose I have to fill the next word,
next word can be anything in the whole
vocabulary, vocabulary.
It depends completely on the vocabulary, but,
but the expected next word, you can say that it is a winner
or lucky or maybe other similar words which can fit here.
Okay? Now what I'm trying to say is suppose now this job
that this fill in the blanks.
Now, RNN has to do, RN has to do how it'll do that one.
So that is what it is shown in this particular
diagram diagrammatic way.
So this H one, H two, H three, what you're seeing,
this is nothing but your RNN head and cell, okay?
RNN head and cells, uh, right?
And then this is this sentence we are processing
as a time stamped manner.
Now that is the usual RNN uh, uh, like, uh,
uh, principle, right?
That we have to process everything one at a time.
So first token is your,
and we are processing your, so your is an input,
obviously it'll be converted as a vector,
and vector will be multiplied by this weight,
weight vector, right?
So this is weight WXHX.
I'm saying because X is my input, X is my output,
sorry, hidden layer.
So the weight between input
and hidden, that is what is represented by excess
and weight between hidden and represented by WHH, right?
So first time I process your, here we have one 10 h,
you do the weighted sum, you do the bias followed
by the 10 h, whatever, it gets the output here, it feeds
to the next time stamp.
The next time stamp, you get the output which gets
multiplied by WHS comes here, and the next time is time.
You also have one more input,
which is the current state input that is mobile.
So you process mobile here
and you process the output,
which is coming from last time step H one, right?
Similarly we do for next token, that is number
than is then selected.
Then as, so what is happening is in the r
and n, this is how we process, right?
So this, this context,
the context here is your mobile number is selected
as this is the context, okay?
And this context is very, very short.
Like hardly it has 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 tokens
or six words right?
Now, when your contexts are simpler like this, then
for the RN it is easy to remember that
what is the first word it has seen?
What is the second word it has seen?
What is the third word it has seen?
It is very easier for, for RN to remember,
and hence it'll do the prediction y hat, which can be some
of the word which can fit here more appropriately.
Like a winner. Your mobile number is selected as a winner.
Okay? Now this is how the short term context looks like,
and this is how the RNN processes is, okay?
And it for RN is, it is easier to process it, okay?
I'll take you through the one more scenario.
This is also the same task, next four protection task.
But now the context is bigger, okay? Context is bigger.
I'll read it for you and so that you'll understand.
So the context is goes something like I am from France.
Once I visited India,
I visited many places like Delhi
where people mostly speak Hindi, Ana,
where the native language is Tamil,
where the native language is Tamil.
I also visited famous, uh, moments such as
Taral, India Gate and many historical places.
I met people from different regions, followed, uh,
followed, uh, different region,
followed different tradition, tasted different cuisines,
and experienced diverse culture cultures across the country.
There are many tourist places in India
where people from all over the world
visit throughout the year.
India is known for its unity
and diversity, culturally, linguistically, and socially.
At last, I must say India is very diverse by culture
and by language still.
I never felt any difficulty
because I got a right guide with whom I use
to fluently speak in, and the rigid fill in the blanks.
Now you tell me what is the next word which you think
that will come here?
More approach. French. French, yeah. French.
Any other, any other option if you can, anyone can think of
Maybe English also, sir,
because friend people might speak English as mm,
and Indian people are, we also speak English fluently. Got
It? Correct.
Okay, so English, it might be some other, uh,
word which is possible, which is coming here, right?
So what I'm trying to say here is obviously English
or French, both are, you can say that the
expected next word, but if you see more appreciate this is
1 1, 1 person, one tourist, uh, who has come from France
because he's telling that I am from France.
He might be good in English.
I'm not saying that he may be good in Hindi also for
that matter, but then he's from France.
And then the first thing, what can come into our mind is
that it's okay, someone is from Karnataka.
Maybe he's knowing Canada, okay?
Someone is from say that Delhi, then maybe they,
he must be speaking Hindi.
That is the first thing what we can,
the person may also be knowing English.
But the first thing, what you can come in your mind is
that okay, the reason, suppose someone is from
then there is a high probability that he will be knowing
that reason like this, right?
He may not be knowing. Also, suppose I'm from Karnataka
and I have never lived in Karnataka.
I was always abroad, so I never learned the Canada.
That is also possibility,
but possibility of that is very low, right?
So the context is context here.
If I will say this context is very long. Why?
Because in this whole context here,
the here the person has mentioned that I'm from France
after this fourth word,
nowhere in this whole context,
there is any mention about the France.
There is no mention about the France.
And at last I'm suddenly asking the, uh, the model
to predict there should be a French, okay?
Because that is the most appropriately word here.
So now just see the complexity.
The complexity is remembering this long
context is very difficult.
It's really difficult for us also now here,
because the word is so familiar to us, France, French.
So we are able to answer.
But just think about the in general,
if I'll give you any passage and I'll ask you, okay?
Very long passage, long paragraph,
and I'll ask you to give extra prediction.
Even we as a human being, being being will struggle.
Same thing happened with the RL.
Same thing happened with the rn.
Now see, the problem is suppose we have here a hundred,
a hundred such words here.
So the time is stamp will go from zero to hundred one
to hundred zero to 99, whatever it is, right?
So a hundred times stamp where?
So that at the fourth timestamp, I have seen something,
which I have to remember at hundredth timestamp also
because at the hundredth timestamp, I have
to predict French, right?
Because I have to process everything.
Then only I can predict what is the next word?
So something which I have seen at very early of the sequence
that I have to remember carry all the way,
and then I have to predict the next word based on
what I have seen at the fourth trimester.
No, this is really a very difficult job for the models,
at least for the r and n model.
That's why I say that r and n fails, okay?
R and n fails in these places because
whenever the long term con context come,
it is very difficult for the models to remember.
And there is no mechanism also to remember, right?
What we are doing in the RNN is if you see the architecture
of the RN, you process the word
and you, you feed it to the next
and you process the word next time term you feed it
to the next, this process goes on, right?
But when this sequence is small,
we can still have some understanding that what I have seen,
just two words back, three words back,
or four words back, okay?
Maybe the information will definitely lose in
that case also, whatever is one here,
here it is becoming H one plus S two.
So obviously when it reaches to S3, there will be some part
of the H one coming, some part of the S two coming.
But here it was only H one.
So you will have more understanding of the H one
as you'll go away from H one.
Say that HH six, you will not be having, uh, the, the,
the weightage, if I, I just talking about the weightage
atachment one will be lesser as compared to S five
or S four HS three.
That is how it's, okay, so obviously this is,
this is just the general, uh, the way
of thinking from the human also, so
that when you are childhood,
when you are attending your high schools
or graduations, you try
to remember the memory from that time, right?
Okay. Obviously, we forget, right?
Even for the, immediately, immediately
after this class, you'll forget many things about the RNN.
And this is what happens as one
is the initial things which you started in the class.
And at six, which we have recently at the last, at 10 15,
you will wind up, maybe you will remember now this one,
and you will forget this, right?
So this is what is the, uh, general, general case,
and that is where the RNN fails also, right?
And this is where the grad, uh, uh,
vanishing gradient problem also, I mean, this is just a,
you can say that non-technical, uh, explanation
of why the RNN fail.
If I'll just, uh, add it to the technical way
that the gradient vanishing.
Okay? The gradient vanishing is nothing, but,
but for the longer sequences are and fails.
So what will happen when you'll have number
of times stamp like that, say hundreds of times,
stamp 300 sub times stamps, right?
And everything you have to process, remember at the last,
and then do the next word prediction
or give the output here.
Now, when you do the back propagation, what happens here
that these, all these waves are hap has to be updated.
All these waves has to be updated, right?
WHS or WXH here, right?
And they go through across the time stem.
So what I mean, there are lot
of gradient multiplications happens.
Lot of, I have to update WHS.
So WHS is not only here, it is here also. It is here also.
It is here also. It is here also, right?
So for every weight, uh, what you have to update, you have
to go all the way from the last up to the starting
because weight is shared from the first time stem
to the last time stem, at least this WHS and WHH.
So your equation becomes so deeper.
And then you are multiplying this with this, this,
with this, this, with this, this, with this.
So then here we have 0.1. It becomes 0.1 into 0.1.
That becomes multiplied with a 0.1 that multiplied with 0.1.
So what will, after certain time going into this,
my gradient becomes very, uh, almost zero, okay?
Or very near to zero. And he hence it vanis.
So your weights gets updated maybe
till this particular point.
And after this, after that, it is not updating.
So what happened? These initial early layers are not
updating, and hence, your RN doesn't learn the longer
sequence and it start forgetting what it has seen at H one
or H two or H three.
Okay? So this is the vanishing gradient problem.
Now, the LSTM addresses this problem.
LS TM addresses this problem.
So I'll just take a few more minutes to, uh,
give my perspective as well.
I'll just try to give you an analogy.
So whatever sir has explained the same thing.
What you can understand now in the,
the problem was in the rn, the problem was, uh,
we have the hidden state
and that theme, hidden state will get updated at the next
time step, and the same will get updated the next time step.
And if the sequence is very long,
then it is very difficult to remember.
What I have already learned at the first time
is step or second time is step.
Now in the LSTM, what we do, we address this problem
by this upper line.
I say that, okay, I'll be updating something here based on
the current state, like xd, whatever is the current input XD
or XT plus one, I'll be definitely updating the,
the 10 H part, okay?
Hidden time hidden, hidden, uh, uh, um, this H one,
this 10 H part, right?
But I also maintain this upper line.
The upper line is my memory, okay?
I also, uh, maintain my memory now in the L sst m now i,
I will just give you the analogy again of the human brain.
So what happened, I was giving the example
of the high schools.
See everything, what you did in your higher schools
or you did in your childhood, in the college, uh,
college days, you might not remember, right?
My majority of the things might have,
you might have forgotten, but there are certain things,
certain moments you still remember.
How is that possible? It is like our brain, right?
So in our brain, we have a memory, okay?
The memory is capable of remembering some longer context.
Longer context, like 10 years, 20 years, 30 years back.
You still remember that. So that memory is there.
So what happened every time now,
when you are attending this particular class,
you have some new information which
you are adding into your memory.
Now, this new information,
whenever you add that new information, is about like xd.
Now say that we were talking about A
and N-R-N-N-L-S, tm, right?
Everything we are talking, when we started r
and n, we say that it can, it can
remember the sequence well,
but suddenly now in this particular class, he said
that no A cannot handle maybe then more the sequence length
in more than 30 or more than 10.
Now this is a new information xd,
which you are getting now in this particular class.
And then when you get this new information,
whatever is your old information that okay,
RN can handle the sequence
or context that you're updating, right?
So what you're doing is based on this new information,
you add something in your memory,
you delete some earlier perception,
what you have kept about the same topic in your memory.
And based on that you have now new learning about
that particular topic in your memory.
So this upper line is like your memory,
which you have maintaining till the time of your birth,
the memory brain, it is still working from,
from the time of your birth.
Every time, every time you get a new information, right?
Many time these information redundant.
And hence you decide that I'll not add anything into here.
I'll not add anything because say
that machine learning you have already learned.
And now, uh, again, you have to learn, for example, say
that, you know, first time when you started driving the car,
you learned it and many things you
added, deleted from the memory.
Now, every day you drive the car information redundant,
you don't add in, but suddenly when in the driving car,
anything new event come that will shake you, right?
And that you will do the addition deletion from the memory.
So this upper line, you can treat it
as the brain and these things.
What is happening in between that, like forget gate
or input gate
or output gate, right here, it is like the, the init,
the based on this current state input
and the, uh, whatever it's coming from back,
you're doing some adaptation in your brain, right?
So that is, that is what you can understand.
So in the forget gate says that based on this current MO
how much you should forget,
like you had some perception about neural network,
which got updated in ENN got updated with CNN
and now being updated with RNN, right?
And maybe, so then you are,
every time when you get new information, you
delete something from it and you add something into memory.
So that is happening here. And then you also expose that one
for the next time a stamp wonder.
Whatever you will do or whatever new information,
you will get it, right?
So this is how the one line, the upper line it is trying
to overcome the limitations of the RNN
because now I maintain my memory from the first time stem.
Whenever I started, I remember everything.
Obviously lot of habitations has happened by forgetting
or adding something into it,
but then I still remember, so upper line remains constant.
You you mean constant in the sense, uh, uh, it,
it is always in place by having some application in
between based on the current input.
So this line is known as memory cell.
My memory or memory of the LSTM
and the other things are like application,
which happens in between, right?
So I, I'll stop here because we have already, uh, done
with 10, 15, maybe try to, uh, kept you on the same line.
If you have any other queries on the
same line, you can ask me.
Then we'll continue the next class.
So, uh, the first two neural net, uh, uh, LSTM cell
actually, uh, the first one is adding the new
information to it. And first
One, this one is forget gate. This one?
Yes, sir. And this is the input
gate together, these two,
But both are, uh, the input gate is adding
to the previous information.
Yes. And then it is,
Yeah, input means adding and forget means deleting.
So deleting means I'm doing some multiplication
because if it is zero, it'll delete that part, right?
Yes. That's why this is called input here.
Yeah. Okay,
Sir, I have a question.
Yes, yes, please, sir. I understand the importance
of new inputs at every cell.
So why do we have to forget as well?
Uh, see, I'll tell you now, uh, I, that's what, when,
when, uh, maybe it is something like, uh,
uh, when you started learning this, say
that machine learning or ai,
you might have some different perception, right?
About, okay, what this machine learning is what it can do,
what it cannot do, or something like that.
Okay? Now,
but as you go inside the depth, you realize that no,
there are some other, other other facts, okay?
About the machine learning,
which I was not knowing initially, but I know that now.
So whatever initial perception I had about
that particular subject, I need to forget
because that was not true
or for true, it was not completely true.
Okay? So that's why forget get is required, right?
So, uh, to, to, to give you the same, same, uh, uh,
um, maybe, uh, some, some examples.
I'm trying to recall what I can give you
that in your general life where you find that, oh, no, no,
no, this I had a wrong perception in my life.
No, this is not happening like that. Okay?
This should be like this.
So there you try to make an effort to like a forget.
You may not immediately forget
or you forget partially of that.
That's why it is smite between zero to one. It's not either.
It's not only zero or one, right?
So, but you try to forget it, right?
So because that is wrong perception about a particular
subject, what you had, and you need to forget it in order,
in order to, uh, uh, in order to update your,
uh, what is that memory?
So that happens. I guess you can recall
that I'm not getting that immediately.
Some, some an analogy to tell you,
but that happens, isn't it?
Yeah. Yeah. What it was, Yeah. Yeah.
So do, um, so, uh, generally for, uh,
we use, uh, sigmoid for gates, right?
Because the output will be always zero in one. Mm-hmm.
So can we use this, uh, or soft max also for the gates?
Uh, no, that, that reason,
the very reason was the, see there is a memory.
I have already my memory now in my memory,
whatever I have, I have options.
I can even retain my memory.
Whatever I have, I can forget everything.
Suppose there is some accident happen to someone, they said,
oh, he he cannot remember anything now, right?
Or there is a possibility that
I forget something and remember something.
These are the possibility of my memory, correct?
Now these are the states which are possible.
Now, if sigmoid can only give you that flexibility
that you can completely forget.
If give, if it gives you zero,
you can completely retain if it is one,
or it can be between zero
and one based on whether it is 0.1, 0.5,
or 0.9, Relu can not give you that one.
That's why Smite is required here
and not any other function, right?
Yeah. Yes.
And this Altium, uh, like, uh, does this,
uh, altium fully, uh, solve this long-term dependencies
or it just improves the when compared to R?
That is what you will forget when we will go
to the next part now, and we, when we were talking about RN
and we said that, uh,
Aaron n can remember the context given whatever, uh,
sentences and all, now we said that no Aaron has a problem,
and you got that new input, we forget it, something,
and now you have in your mind no LSTM is better than RNN
for the longer context going forward.
We'll, we will, we will say
that there is a problem in the LSTM,
also something which we are solving
with the next model maybe.
Yeah. So that's, that's, that's
where you will forget against something
and you will, you will add some new things in your memory
to update that, whatever you had, okay?
So this process goes on entire life.
This is how we as a human also work.
LSTM also works with po.
Obviously the LSTM solves majority of the problem,
but that it has some, some other problem,
which will talk going further.
But yeah, as of now, whatever we have discussed,
it can remember the long, long memory as well.
A long short term memory.
It can maintain with the upper line,
what you're seeing as a memory cell.
It can remember. Yeah.
Okay. Here, um, uh, with the,
with initial, uh, the forget gate, we are multiplying and,
and the we are adding.
Mm, so adding generally means, uh,
we are not losing information,
but multiplying vectors means we are trying
to generally get to the like, uh, cosign similarity
or something like that, right? Correct.
It's a dot product, right?
It's a do product kind of thing. Yeah. So
Now you can just imagine that
before this point we have a vector, okay?
We have a vector where that vector, it says that 0.8, okay?
0.8, okay?
And then it has also says 0.9, say
that these two are the value I have.
Okay? Ready for the drawing.
And now here in the, in the sigmoid,
what we are getting a vector, vector, it says zero
and vector, it says 0.5, anything can come, right?
I don't know what can come, but anything can come.
Now, what will happen in the multiplication,
there is a dot product zero will get multiplied with 0.8,
0.5 will get multiplied with 0.9.
Now, what you will get after this is again a vector.
And then because first, first is zero gets multiplied
with 0.8, you will get here.
Zero means first dimension, you're forgetting everything.
Second dimension, 0.5 gets multiplied with 0.9,
which is 0.45, correct?
Yeah. Uh, so 0.45.
So now before this point, your input was,
the memory was 0.8, 0.9.
After this, this multiplication, you forget something
and now you have zero and 0.45.
So you see that your memory got
updated. This is what happens.
So, so in a way we can say we are retaining, uh, memory
of, uh, XT minus one
and XT where it is aligned, right?
Uh, see, uh, obviously see, uh, any new information, any,
any redundant information when it is coming, you don't want
to update this cell, okay?
Or any information which,
which has broken your earlier thoughts,
you want to forget it.
So say that I had some, uh, I was, I was, I,
I was a supporter of, of I was a supporter of a party one,
but today something happened, which has broken my heart,
said what I had that new information,
I'm completely making zero.
And that this gets mapped here.
And after that, from today onwards,
I'll never support that party.
So this, this zero says that I'm completely for uh, uh,
whatever I was supporter of a particular party.
I from now onwards, I'm not going to be.
So whenever a new,
and based on this xt, this is the DExT, which is making me
to take that call, that now I'm not going
to remember this particular information anymore,
okay? This is something like,
So it's not like, uh, um, both are um, like
influencing and then you're getting a result.
It's like the, the,
the later one xts influencing are even filtering out
XT minus one information to some extent
Obviously see XT minus one is also flowing here, right?
Yeah. So in the RN or LSTM, there are always two inputs.
The current state input
and last time stent output that also.
So both the things are influencing both the things.
You can see that here, both the things are combining here
and then it goes here,
Okay, sir? Yeah, yeah.
Uh, Like, uh, in the scenario of video analytics, sir,
like we have to scan, uh, a video for a period
of half an hour to one hour.
So at time I will not use RN, I'll go
for LSM kind of models.
So video is a sequence of frames, right? Yes.
And yes, wherever there is a sequence you can use RNN,
but with the video, which is nothing
but a frame within nothing
but an image, there is an extra complexity
that image it is better to handle with the CNN
that we have already talked about.
So what we can do is, in that case,
you can definitely use RNN to have
that sequence information in the frames
but crosses that frames initially.
You can use the CNN, that is
Okay, Okay?
So XD will be the image or frame
before going here in the RNN, you can place it in
between CNN, which can first understand the image features
well, and then feed it to the RN
to understand the sequence information in the frame.
That is how CRNN that is.
People have used convolution and then RN concept together.
Okay? So they have mixed both the
concepts and they used it.
Okay? So,
but uh, like since I'm saying like I want to scan a video
for more than one hour or two hours.
So we have a long term dependency, sir.
So other term RN will be better performance
or LS team we can go for the
Same. Oh, between Aaron
and Lium, you are telling that? Yes.
Yes Sir. It is the same pro. It is the same thing.
If you have very longer context, you should go for the lstm.
We go from the LST kind. Simple, okay.
Yeah. Okay.
So I guess it might have given you a little more clarity
than uh, uh, that what is LSTM
and uh, RNN, how it is different from how it addresses.
Now, one more thing, what I tried to cover today was this,
uh, back propagation and types of the rn
and that will cover in the next class, even Monday,
we'll meet again and then I'll cover that.
Yes, sure, sir. Sure, sir.
It was very good explanation. This, sir. Thank you sir.
Thank you. Thank you all. Thank you, sir.
Sir, thank You sir. Uh, sir, uh, one last question.
Uh, so this is re not regarding the, uh, theory. Mm-hmm.
So any tentative dates for the end semester exam, sir?
Oh, you people have not received anything?
We, we didn't receive, sir, sir?
Oh yeah, I guess 22nd is the last working day.
I was just talking yesterday with Garris, sir.
He said that after two weeks, uh, in March, second week
or so, the exam will start, uh, we,
you will get the, uh, exact date.
Uh, but after two weeks means second weeks
or third week he says, I don't remember clearly,
but I think second week
of parts examination will start, I guess then,
Uh, okay, sir, So there is a mention in CIP,
but I think to share details.
Oh, okay. Okay. Then I'll, I'll ask him to share as soon
as possible by finalizing it. Okay? Yes.
Maybe Gap is better, sir.
Like we had last time, that is a gap.
We add only two weeks, gap only.
Mm-hmm. A two weeks gap will be
there, first of all, I guess.
And then exams will be only on Saturday or Sunday.
Uh, that weekday, that is no exams.
So those things will take care this, uh,
the same way what we did.
Okay?
Yes. Sure. Thank
You, sir. Thank,
Thank.